you only eat meat still yep
talk me through a day's diet uh strip
wine strip wine steak you wake up in the
morning what do you have for breakfast
strip wine what do you have for lunch
what do you have for dinner sometimes
Stripling in soup you have three steaks
a day yeah yeah no vegetables or
anything you just nope nothing just a
steak yeah do you have any sauce no it
was kind of fascinating how long have
you done this six years yeah six years
in December you look like you're
bursting with good health I mean what
are what are the experts say about this
uh depends on the experts but mostly you
know you should have died by now is
usually the reaction they get